economía en directo América de France 24
me acompaña en el estudio Juan Pablo
lucumí Juan Pablo buena mañana de
miércoles y vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos porque no hay tan buenas noticias
para Donald Trump porque la compañía de
bienes raíces sobre la que el
expresidente construyó su imperio fue
condenada de que se la acusa Y de qué se
trata esto Juan Pablo Buenos días Raúl
pues hay que tener en cuenta que se le
acusa a la empresa organización Trump y
no al expresidente estadounidense en sí
mismo los fiscales dijeron que la
compañía evadió impuestos de manera
criminal y suprimió Los costos de nómina
al beneficiar a sus ejecutivos con bonos
no declarados como arrendamientos de
autos y apartamentos de lujo los 17
cargos de culpabilidad entregados por
Pues el Jurado del estado de Nueva York
podrían generar multas de 1,6 millones
de dólares para la organización Trump
que opera hoteles campos de golf y otras
propiedades inmobiliarias en todo el
mundo como era de esperarse los abogados
de la empresa dijeron que apelarán pero
que se concentrarán en no en negar Pues
los delitos sino en demostrar que estos
no se cometieron en nombre de la empresa
el juez fijo el 13 de enero como fecha
de Sentencia Juan Paola revisemos los
datos económicos de Europa tenemos los
datos recién liberados de eurostat desde
el crecimiento económico de la zona Euro
y la Unión Europea que recordemos Raúl A
diferencia de la Unión Europea que es un
bloque económico y político la zona de
oro es una Unión monetaria es decir
países que comparten la misma moneda el
crecimiento económico de los 19 países
que comparten el euro fue ligeramente
más fuerte de lo previsto en el tercer
trimestre pues eurostats la oficina de
estadística de la Unión Europea había
estimado A mediados de noviembre un
crecimiento del 0,2% y Cómo podemos ver
aumentó un
0,3%, Mientras que el bloque de los 27
creció un 0,4% en el mismo periodo Bueno
ahora nos vamos hasta Asia y nos
quedamos ahí para revisar varias
noticias destacadas de ese Juan Pablo
empezamos con una de las más importantes
la relajación general de las normas
sanitarias en China una noticia que
tratamos aquí en esta sección porque el
anuncio puede calmar a los mercados
mundiales que tienen los ojos puestos
encima de la segunda Economía del mundo
y es que el comercio internacional
Espera que china pase de lado esta etapa
estricta de normas de covid justo en
época navideña y de Cara a una inminente
recesión en diferentes partes del mundo
que aquí lo hemos recopilado en varias
ocasiones dentro de el cambio en las
políticas se reducirá la frecuencia y el
alcance de las pruebas de pcr los
cierres que han hecho enojar a la
población y las autoridades esperan
liberar las áreas que no muestren casos
positivos Después de cinco días algo que
el gobierno chino no ha abandonado es no
abandonado por completo son las
restricciones de viaje y las pruebas
intensivas para sus ciudadanos
escuchemos
instalaciones escuelas primarias y
secundarias y otros lugares especiales
ya era necesario proporcionar evidencia
de resultados negativos de pruebas de
ácido nucleico códigos de salud y
códigos de viaje tampoco se hará más el
tamizaje de las personas que se
trasladan de una región a otra
seguimos en Asia Juan Pablo para hablar
de la economía de Corea del Sur Por qué
las autoridades dijeron que la economía
de su país está recuperando del impacto
inicial de una huelga nacional
protagonizada por miles de camioneros de
carga pesada Pese a que ya cumple 14
días sin embargo el gobierno de johnsol
culpó a los huelguistas de costarle a la
economía más de 2,600 millones de
dólares en un momento de incertidumbre
financiera mundial
Juan Pablo y cómo va la puja entre la
inflación y los tipos de interés en
India este miércoles El Banco Central de
ese país anunció un incremento del 6,25%
en la tasa de interés superior al límite
del 6% que se tenía pactado a inicio de
año la nueva medida llega para hacerle
frente a la inflación en el país
asiático que según las autoridades sigue
por encima del nivel superior de
tolerancia en octubre el índice de
precio es el consumidor fue del 6,8%
interanual vamos ahora con Los
indicadores económicos seguimos hablando
de Asia seguimos hablando de Asia porque
pues hoy estos temas van a afectar en
general a los mercados mundiales las
bolsas asiáticas cerraron en terreno
negativo luego del anuncio de que Apple
fabricará chips en Estados Unidos para
reducir su dependencia de China y
también muy atentos a cómo pueda
reaccionar la población a las medidas de
covid las bolsas en Europa siguen
operando mayoritariamente a la baja con
el anuncio de que el mercado mayorista
más grande de Europa ha tenido profundas
salsas en sus de Cara a la temporada
navideña que nos trae hoy como si fuera
el día china tuvo un 12% más de
importaciones de petróleo crudo en el
mes de noviembre respecto al mismo mes
del año pasado seguimos hablando de
China lo que supone el nivel más alto en
10 meses con
46,74 millones de toneladas de El
hidrocarburo para el mayor importador de
crudo del mundo Juan Pablo Gracias por
toda la información de economía más
adelante por supuesto echamos más
números aquí en directo América así es